first let's talk about the percent
proportion so basically what it is is a
proportion is a ratio that's equal to
another ratio and a ratio is just a
fraction where you're comparing two
quantities or it could be written as a
fraction so what we have here is we have
P over 100 and P represents the percent
so percent means per hundred meaning
like something divided by a hundred so
like forty percent is actually 40 parts
out of 100 parts right equals is over of
so you're gonna see the words isn't of
and these problems are going to be doing
is is the part and of is out of meaning
out of the total just like a hundred
percent is the total out of that's the
total so what we're doing is we're
comparing the part out of the whole or
the total equals the part out of the
whole which is the total so those two
ratios are equal and it makes a
proportion and we can solve so let's get
into an example number one here and says
16 is forty percent of what number okay
so what we're going to do is we've got
forty percent so that's gonna go in for
P here so we have 40 over 100 okay 16 is
okay that's the part Oh what number
meaning out of what number we don't know
what that is so we're gonna make that a
variable X okay so with me so far so
then all we have to do is cross multiply
and solve now what a lot of students
will do okay and a lot of teachers will
recommend is if you can reduce these
these fractions first before you do the
cross multiplying that makes the problem
a little bit easier so I'm going to do I
the top and the bottom by 10 when you
divide by 10 this is just going to
become 4 and this is going to be 10
which we can reduce further to 2/5 okay
so now we have two fifths equals 16 over
X I'm going to cross multiply on the
diagonal so 2 times X is 2x 5 times 16
is 80 and if we divide both sides by 2
you can see that x equals 40 so that's
the answer to this question 16 is
actually 40 percent of 40 okay start
here with me so far
okay let's go on to example number two
this one says what is 30 percent of 48
okay so here we say 30 percent that's
the P over here so 30 parts out of 100
all right equals now what is now here we
don't know what the part is that is so
that's going to be X
all 48 meaning out of 48 okay so you see
how I did that is we don't know out of
48 and then 30% is 30 parts out of 100
all we have to do is cross multiply and
solve let's reduce a little bit here
first so if we divide the top and bottom
by 10 we can reduce this fraction to
3/10 so now when we cross multiply we
get 3 times 48 which is how much that's
let's see that's 48 times 3 that's 100
in 46 right 144 there we go
and that's 10x and if we divide both
sides by 10 you can see that x equals
14.4 okay so then the last example
before I get into that I just wanted to
say I'm gonna have another video talking
about how to work with the percent
equation that's another way to solve
these problems I'm gonna do a separate
video with that I'll have a link for
that and I also wanted to say if you're
enjoying these videos you know subscribe
to the channel and also check out my
patreon page I'll have a link for that
if you want to support the making of
these videos and it's benefiting you and
you want to help other students as well
learn check out my patreon page but
let's get into the last example here it
says 21 is 15% of what number
ok so here we go 15% that's 15 parts out
of a hundred
ok 21 is alright so that's 21 of what
number again we don't know so that's
going to be X so all we have to do is
again cross multiply and solve and
you've got it so one example that I
didn't show in here is sometimes you can
solve for the percentage so they'll say
what you know % is this number out of
this number and you would just leave P
as your variable and you could again you
can cross multiply as long as you know
three of the four quantities here you
just have one unknown you'll be able to
solve so again I hope you enjoyed this
video subscribe to the channel and I
look forward to seeing in the future
videos